let's move on to our second speaker
today
it is my pleasure to introduce you to dr
john
du garzagoyfea from the department of
pathology
yale university school of medicine the
title of this talk
is discovery of biomarkers associated
with benefit
from pd1 checkpoint blockade
non-small cell lung cancer using iplex
digital spatial profiling
please join me in welcoming dr
zugazagoysa
i will turn the presentation over to me
okay good morning everyone and thank you
first of all to
nano string and all the organizers for
inviting me to share
our work with you in this nice virtual
conference
and this presentation will be related to
a work that we did when i was at jail
related to discovery
of new biomarkers of response to immune
checkpoint
therapy in normal muscle lung cancer
using digital spatial profiling
so first of all i'm going to start with
an in an
introduction uh sharing with you the
idea of why we need
a new biomarkers of response to
immunotherapy particularly
in lung cancer and what are the issues
with some of the biomarkers that we are
using currently
in the clinics such as pdl one so
as some of you know most of the patients
with lung cancer that receive
pd1 axis inhibitors actually do not
benefit from them
in the long term as you can see on the
on the left hand side the five-year
overall survival with nivolumab in this
case is around
15 in unselected non-small cell lung
cancer patients
if we select them for a pdl one
for pdl1 status meaning that if we give
these drugs to patients with a
pdl one to more proportion score greater
than 50 percent which are those more
likely
to benefit from these drugs even in this
ideal situation
not the ma the majority of patients
actually do not benefit from the drugs
in the long term as you can see response
rates
are around 40 percent in this high pdl-1
population
and the five-year overall survival still
remains to a minority of patients about
30 percent of them
so this clearly shows us that we need
better biomarkers particularly
for a monotherapy or for selecting
candidate patients for monotherapy with
these drugs
and pdl one as you know is the only
biomarker that we currently use in the
clinic to
to to select patients to give these
drugs
and as you as you already know i'm not
going to spend too much time on this but
pdl one has its
limitations and i'm gonna share with you
two
two of those that i think are more
important first of all is
i'm showing here this is the way
pathologists score pdl one and this is
the way pathologists tell us
uh the the the amount of pdl1
that there is in a in a given tumor of a
patient and as you can see here
pdl one scoring by pathologies is
inevitably qualitative
they gave us they give us the proportion
of cells
the proportion of tumor cells that are
positive
for pdl pdl1 but this this acid doesn't
really take into account
the the the staining or at least the
intensity of the staining
so it's actually an a qualitative assay
and
we we are losing a lot of information
here
and the other limitation that i see as
an important limitation in the clinic
is that although there is good
concordance between pathologists to
score
a tumor cell pdl-1 as you can see here
the
the the icc scores for
pathologies concordance are above 0.8
which is good for tumor cell scoring but
it's not good at all
for immune cell scoring as you can see
here and we we don't really know
if the predictive value of pdl1 comes
from tumor cells or immune cells and
this is something
important to take into account and this
poor con
poor interrupt cerebral reproducibility
for immune cell pdl one scoring has been
shown in other studies this is
this is the second the second one that
that came up to the same conclusion
that pathologists are there there's good
concordance between
pathologists for scoring a tumor cell
pdl one
but not so much for immune cell pdl one
so at the end of the day
particularly for immune cell pdl one
this is not a very reproducible assay
and we need
more objective for automated methods for
scoring pdl one
and also other markers so with this idea
we kind of developed or we initiated a
study
with the aim to identify biomarkers of
response in this case to single agent
pd1
checkpoint blockade using a
geomics digital spatial profiling
so what we did is we took
a retrospective cohort of immunotherapy
treated non-muscle and cancer patients
at yale at a single institution we
collected
their tumors and these tumors were
represented in a tissue microarray
we as we we assessed two non-adjacent
tumor cores per
a non-muscle lung cancer case using as i
said the geomics
beta system that we had at tl a year
a year ago or so and we used the
44 plex a protein panel
and these proteins were assessed er
simultaneously
in four different tissue compartments
as as we will as we will see later
and for the statistical analysis we did
a compartment-specific
outcome association analysis for
progression-free survival
overall survival and clinical benefit
exploring
two different cut points for each marker
as you can see we did multiple
comparisons here but well this
this was initiated as a discovery study
so we are
we are allowed to do multiple
comparisons we did
actually multiplicity adjustment in
order to avoid
false discovery false discoveries and we
use the benjamini hospital
a false discovery adjustment method and
we
adjusted for a number of comparisons per
per compartment and separately
for each of the explored cut ones
and finally we did multivariate analysis
in order to find markers that was
significantly associated with outcome
independently from clinical prognostic
factors in this case performance status
smoking history presence of liver
metastasis or lipid score
which we know is strongly prognostic in
these patients
so that slide and well this is the a
cohort that we used uh
i'm explaining here the clinical
characteristics of this
a retrospective cohort it contains
a total of 81 cases and these are the
clinical characteristics here that
resembles pretty much
what we usually see in a routine
clinical setting as you can see these
were patients treated with a variety of
different treatments but we were
particularly
interested in this group of patients
receiving a monotherapy
with a pd-1 or pdl-1 inhibitors
and this was the panel the protein panel
that we used
in this case for discovery of biomarkers
in spatial context this was the
this this has a total of 40 markers plus
controls and these are markers related
as you know with
immune cell composition also markers
related to
functional orientation of the
immune filtration and also with some
targets that are important for t-cells
particularly
and we used three visualization markers
in this case antibodies to detect a
tumor cells with pancetta carotene
to detect immune cells with z45 and to
detect
specifically macrophages with cd68
staining
so this is how the the the kind of
images that we
that we got in this in this study this
is showing
a tma spot stained with three different
visualization antibodies as you can see
here
in green cytochromatin positive two more
cells
in yellow uh cd45 positive
immune cells and in red
these are cd68 positive macrophages as
you can see
and in in blue these are cells that as
you can see there are
in the in the stroma as well but do not
stain positive
either for cd45 or cd68 they are
presumably fibroblasts
and this is the way that the geomic
system
actually does tissue
compartmentalization remember that our
primary objective here was to identify
biomarkers
associated with outcome in spatial
context
so that's why we measured all these 40
markers
in four different compartments and this
compartmentalization is shown
here the the system
kind of co-localizes the
fluorescent signal to create this tissue
compartment
or masks as you can see here and this is
the
epithelial or tumor compartment shown in
green
the leukocyte compartment shown in
yellow the specifically the macrophage
compartment shown in blue here
and finally a fourth compartment which
is the
non-immune cell stroma which are cells
as i said before that are positive for
nuclear staining
but they are negative for a cytokeratin
cd45 or cd68
and then in order to make all the
samples as comparable
as possible we did area and
normalization
so first of all samples or compartments
with less than 10 nuclei or less than
100 micron surface area were excluded
from the
from the analysis at least in our hands
was very difficult to
er to obtain reliable quantitative
information for
very small areas remember that we are
measuring immune markers that sometimes
they are expressed
or usually they are expressed at very
low levels so it was
it was hard to to quantify them from
very very tiny areas that's why
we we kind of excluded them from this
analysis
those samples that passed this filter
weren't then normalized
by surface area as i said in order to
make all the samples
as comparable as possible and we use
this this formula
and this is kind of summarizing all the
methods that we that we used in this
consort diagram
so we had a total of 81 cases included
in ytma-404
from these cases a total of 67 cases
were finally collected from two
different blocks these blocks contain
two more cores that are non-adjacent
from each of the cases and as you can
see here
from these 67 cases 53
of those had protein biopsies and
received single agent billy one second
blockade and this was
our target population this was the our
true discovery cohort
so in these 33 cases we measured 40
immune parameters in four different
compartments two more compartments cd45
compartment cd68 compartment and finally
non-immunes and stroma
and these are the number of valuable
cases per compartment
after excluding those that have
very small areas or areas with
less than 10 nuclei as you can see for
example there were 42
available patients for cd45 related
discoveries because not all tumors as
you know
contain immune filtration so we had to
exclude them for the cd45 related
discoveries
so i will start showing you some
analytic results
first as you can see first in order to
prove
the performance of the assay we kind of
calculated
the normalized counts for each of the of
the markers
and then we also calculated the signal
to background ratio
in order to to to show that the
performance of the assay
i'm showing here an example of one of
the markers that was showing really high
counts
and really and really good signal to
background ratios
this was the case for sting measured in
the tumor compartment as you can see
a lot of tumors express high levels of
sting
and most of the cases have signal to
background ratios way above background
as you can see
way above three or way above five this
is a market that is
showing a really good performance
but there were also another other
markets that as you can see here
they were expressed as uh at lower
levels so in this case
the signal to background ratios for some
of these uh
markers in this case like three was
below three meaning that we cannot
really distinguish between
a true signal from background and this
was the case from
five markers as you can see here which
had signal to background ratios less
than three
in all compartments and in the vast
majority of the cases
so we decided to exclude these markers
from
outcome analysis because we we weren't
really
or we couldn't really distinguish
through signal from
from background from from these markers
and also another thing that we that we
that we realized was that the the fourth
compartment which was the non-immune
cell stromal compartment
in this compartment there were really
low counts for
most of the new markers which is not
surprising because we are measuring
immune markers
in in in a tissue compartment which
which which has not which doesn't have
immune cells so at the end of the day
this was also
some kind of validation for us in order
to prove that we were actually
doing a spatial spatial measurement as
you can see here
and there were almost there was almost
no cd3
counts in the non-immune cells from a
compartment as compared to the to the
cd45 compartment
and also we kind of explored what was
the correlation
between counts from different
areas of the tumor per
per case and as you can see there were
markers where the regression between
different
areas of the tumor was quite good in the
range of 0.6
and 0.7 in some of the cases this was
true for sting
or hladr but there were other markers
where the heterogeneity was
substantially higher and the correlation
between different areas of the tumor was
lower
and actually this was the case for those
immune markers that are expressed
at lower levels or they are more
heterogeneous so at the end
this regression is showing us or is a
function of
marker abundance and tissue
heterogeneity as you can see here
and finally we did the outcome analysis
this was the
primary objective of the study
as you can see here we found a number of
markers that were associated with
outcome
in spatial context actually there were
18 markers associated with either
progression free survival or overall
survival as you can see on the table in
the left hand side
those were markers that were associated
with outcoming the univariate analysis
after doing multiplicity adjustment and
and
doing also multivariate analysis there
were five markers that remained
significantly associated with outcome
and those five markers were vista and
cd127 which is the receptor for
a il-7 in the tumor compartment
and cd4 beta2 microglobaline and cd3
were markers associated with outcome in
the cd45 compartment
were also their markers
that were significant in the univariate
analysis but they didn't hold
significant and after adjusting for
multiplicity
or after controlling for clinical
factors this was the case for pdl1 for
example
pdl1 was associated with overall
survival
only when measured in the immune cells
or
specifically in macrophages as you can
see here we didn't find significance for
pdl1
when this one pda1 was measured in the
tumor compartment
and there was also other markers more
classically associated with outcome as
well such as cd8 here which was
associated with overall survival but
again
it didn't hold significant after
adjusting for
multiple comparisons kind of
highlighting the idea that perhaps it's
not all about cd8
cells there are other cells and other
markers that are contributing
to the benefit of immune check
complicating lung cancer
and just to highlight the
the most relevant discoveries for us i'm
showing them here
that high levels of cd4 and cd56 which
is a marker for
natural killer cells in the cd45
compartment
both were predicted for all clinical
outcomes including
response rate longer progression free
survival
and longer overall survival and this was
true
after controlling for clinical factors
and high levels of vista and cd127 in
the tumor compartment were markers
associated with resistance
actually shorter progression free
survival this was
also a remarkable finding because we we
really need markers with high negative
predictive value in order to exclude
those patients that are not going to
benefit from these drugs
and this was a finding that we thought
it's in
it it was interesting
so i'm going to start showing the
outcomes for pdl one
as you can see pdl one was not
significantly associated with overall
survival when it was measured in the
tumor compartment but it was associated
at least in the univariate analysis
when it was measured in the cd68
compartment
it is true that this significance didn't
stand after
a controlling for multiple comparisons
this is perhaps the limitation of the
study or a limitation of the cohort
because it's not perhaps well powered to
to show significance for pdl1 which we
know is a marker
associated with with with response and
overall survival in lung cancer but
actually this macrophage pdl one
predictive value we did find the same
thing
in a parallel study that was conducted
by another member
of the lab in here
she quantified or this was a work
aimed to quantify immune cell pdn1 in
different immune cell populations and as
you can see
macrophages were expressed in bdl1
a lot actually 80 percent of the immune
systel one
or the stromal peter one was coming from
the macrophage and again
as we as we found with the dsp
the pdl1 in the macrophage in the
macrophages was predictive
of outcome but pdl one in two more cells
was not kind of giving us
some sort of a validation as well of the
dsp finding although this was
done in the same set of patients but
with a different technology
so proceeding with those findings that
we
think are more relevant or at least more
uh
they deserve further validation this is
actually one of them
i'm showing here that those tumors with
high levels of expression of cd127
in the tomb specifically in the tumor
compartment was associated with
resistance
this is a nice example of why
a spatial information is important
because as you can see here
when cd 127 was measured in the tumor
compartment those were high levels those
patients with high levels
of cd127 in the tumor cells were doing
worse
but when measured when c 127 was
measured in the cd45 compartment
this had no association with outcome
again showing the importance of
measuring in a spatial context
and this was the uh another
relevant finding in in our study that
cd56 and cd4
when measured both in the cd45
compartment were predictors of all
clinical outcomes
this is showing the distribution of the
quantification
of a for in this case cd56 and cd4
and these are the couple of meter cores
for progression free survival here
and overall survival in this case for
cd56 and cd4
and as you can see both of them are
markers quite strongly associated with
both progression fish survival and
overall survival
so in order to give
more so on these findings we decided to
prove this outcome association
with another orthogonal quantitative
method
and we decided to validate cd56 as a
marker of nk cells because this was a
more novel finding to us
so we decided to assess cd56 expression
using
a different quantitative method in this
case inform
and this is a method that measures
or counts cells so we developed the
panel
to detect nk cells using
cytokeratine cd3 and cd
cd56 as the marker of natural killer
cells
and we did inform analysis as follows
first we did tissue segmentation in this
case tumor and stroma
then we did cell segmentation to
identify individual cells
and then we phenotype these cells to
distinguish between cd60 cd56 positive
tumor cells
as you know some tumors can express also
two muscles can be positive for cd56
particularly
if they have neuroendocrine features
so we decided so we we wanted to exclude
or to distinguish between these two more
cells
and cd56 positive immune cells
and also between this cd56 immune cell
we wanted to
count separately those that are negative
for cd3
which are nk cells and those that are
double positive for cd3 and c56 which
are
nk diesels so i'm showing now
some pictures in order to to to show you
that actually we could identify
all these cell phenotypes this is a
this is an image acquired with the
vector system and as you can see we are
detecting here
two more cells in green cd3 positive
lymphocytes in in red and cd56 cells
in white and as you can see there are
actually
nk cells here which are cells
here in white but there are also some
nkt cells which are not very abundant
but
but but you can find them here in the
stroma which are double positive for
both cd56 and cd3
and using this orthogonal method
actually we we found
a very similar or we came to the same
conclusion
that cd50 the number of cd56 positive
cells in the stroma were actually
predictive for both
progression-free survival and overall
survival somehow validating
our dsp finding with a degree of
clinical outcome very similar to what we
observed using a dsps
as our discovery tool here is showing
the distribution
and also showing here on the left hand
side that those patients with clinical
benefits
are actually the proportion of cells in
the stroma was was higher as you can see
here
so this is the these are the conclusions
of this
discovery work in
well as you can see the geomix dsp
system
is is well suited for immunotherapy
biomarker discovery as shown in this
work
and these are the main reasons why i
think this is important first because it
is quantitative
because it provides a spatial resolution
and information about cell-to-cell
interactions
and also because it offers a
comprehensive integration of what's
happening
in the whole context of the tumor
microenvironment
and the main conclusion of our work was
that we identified a number of candidate
immunotherapy predictors in spatial
context that of course deserve
validation in larger and independent
cohorts remember that we only had one
cohort
these findings need to be considered
discovery findings that
deserve validation independent
patient data sets or independent cohorts
and this is actually something that is
currently
ongoing and with that i just wanted to
acknowledge uh well on the lab
while i was at jail particularly david
dream who was an extraordinary
leader and mentor and thanks also to
the rest of the team and that was
supporting us
during this work thank you very much for
your attention
thank you dr zugazagoyza for a very
interesting presentation
can you please clarify how many rois
were selected for each non-muslim cancer
case
that you analyzed in your study
yeah so this work was entirely performed
on
tissue microarrays so for that we
we assessed two tissue core
per non-small cell lung cancer case and
these cores that were included in the
in the tissue microarrays they have
0.6 millimeters diameter
so we kind of draw a region of interest
in each of these
cores in the tma so at the end we
assessed
two rois of about 0.6 millimeters
which which which is about 0.28
millimeters square tissue area per
non-small cell lung cancer case
two per case
thank you do you think that the cd3
restricted compartment
would have increased the performer or
some of the biomarker you tested
yeah actually this is certainly a
possibility because as i showed
you before in the analytical results
some of the markers
were expressed uh at low levels or at
least the signal to background ratio of
some markers uh was was quite low
and we believe that this might relate
uh to the fact that these are markers
that are expressed as
particularly uh by t-cells so perhaps
instead of
doing these big cd45
compartments perhaps a more restricted
cd3 compartment could have increased
certainly the signal of some of these
markers such as lag 3 which we know is
explicitly expressed by t-cells
so perhaps a cd-3 related
compartmentalization could have
increased
the signal to noise ratio on some of
these markers and
and therefore increase their their
performance
this is certainly a possibility
thank you in the orthogonal validation
of the cd56 as a candidate
predictor using inform
did you generate a cd45 compartment as
you have done
in the geomics analysis thank you
yes so for the orthogonal validation we
actually
didn't create a scd-45 compartment
we just segmented the tissue in two
compartments
in this case it was a tumor compartment
and the stroma
so with this tissue segmentation with
inform
the stroma actually contains the cd45
compartment that was created with
with dsp this was perhaps
some kind of limitation in our
orthogonal validation but as we came up
to a very similar conclusion
we kind of believe that actually
most of the nk cells that we were
counting in this drama using inform
are actually found or actually located
in a cd45
restricted compartment as we as we saw
with
with the dsp but but yeah we didn't
create a third compartment
with the orthogonal validation
thank you what do you think is the main
novelty in this biomarker discovery work
meaning what does this study add
to other similar you know immunotherapy
biomarker discovery studies
yes so i think the the main novelty of
the study is that we used a different
approach to discover biomarkers and this
approach
was that we were actually trying to find
markers measured in a compartment
specific manner we
were trying to to find markers
associated with outcome
in a spatial context and i think this is
the the main
novelty of the of this discovery study
that we actually
demonstrate that it is important to
measure markers but also to measure them
in in a particular compartment because
this is where they are doing their work
and this is where the
the the predictive capacity of these
markers
relies and that's why this kind of
technology
enabled us to to do this and actually
we did find some really interesting
discoveries in in a spatial context that
deserve further validation but
i think this is the the main novelty
that we measure markers
from different compartments in space
thank you finally can you please
comment about the clinical implication
of the finding in these studies
study
well well perhaps it's a bit early to
to to answer that question because well
as you know this is a
this genomic geometrics dsp is
is a research platform so it's a bit
early to talk about
its potential clinical implications also
we need to consider that
this was worked on on unselected
patients that received
pd1 or pdl1 monotherapy
and we are kind of giving these drugs
less frequently in unselected patients
but apart from that i think that this
kind of demonstrates
or or or suggests that it is important
to measure markers from
a specific compartments
and the dsp workflow is relatively
simple and it uses ffpe
tissue samples and perhaps although it's
a bit early
to talk about this right now but with
further validation this is an assay or a
platform that could
eventually make it into the clinic if
these findings
are confirmed in independent cohorts and
larger codes
so just to give a brief summary of this
uh work and
my take-home message would be that
in this work we show the potential of
the geomix dsp
platform to to discover
biomarkers of response in a novel way
and these novel ways related to this
compartment specific
measurement of biomarkers of response
and this illustrates the potential of
the technology and these findings will
need to be validated in
independent cohorts but i think it's a
very good start
these are some of them are novel
and interesting findings that we will
actually try to validate
in a future cohorts thank you very much
thank you again dr the godzilla for your
presentation
and discussion